So there's a whole bunch of
different inputs and outputs.
And actually, let me open
up this in another tab.
I'll just went up
there because there
are many examples for the
different inputs and outputs.
So here we have inputs.
So what we saw before
was the slider input.
And if you click
on this over here,
you'll see a really
basic example of that.
But there's also text input,
so I can enter texture.
Let's say , hello shiny.
And this example app will
show how to use that.
These numeric input.
So it's similar to the text
input but uses a number input
and there's a
little arrows on it.
Checkbox input, which you
can just turn on and off
by checking it--
or sorry, by clicking on it.
And there's a whole
bunch of other ones.
So there's groups of checkboxes.
There's radio buttons.
There's a select input
that has a dropdown
box and dates and date ranges.
So these are the built-in
inputs for shiny.
With all these inputs, they
all have a common format,
where you say
ui.input something.
And then the first
thing that it's
going to have here, the
first argument that it takes
is an ID, and then
a label for it.
And then there's typically
other parameters as well.
So in this case, we're not using
any of the other parameters.
So if we go to the
slider input, you'll
have to set the minimum
and maximum value
for the slider, as well as
well as the starting value.
One thing that you
can do with these
is, if you have an idea
of the kind of components
that you want to add
to your application is.
Let's say, we're working
on this application here,
and we want to add a
checkbox to it, if we want
to be able to negate the value.
So I can say, well, I'll put a
comma there just because that
will help this auto completion.
I can say ui.input_checkbox,
and then parenthesis,
and then I can give it a name
like negate and Negate slider
value.
I'll use that as a label.
And I can click on
this button and it
will provide this
checkbox, which
right now doesn't do anything.
We need to actually use
it in our application.
So let's see.
So let's say-- how
would we do this here?
So we simply say if
input.negate, then
call this multiplier
equals negative 1
else multiplier equals 1.
And then I can put this here.
And if I rerun this,
then this will work here.
No, I didn't actually fix the
texture with this n times 2.
But you can see how this works
that just simply clicking
on this will cause
this code to re-execute
and this value will be updated.
And, again, if there's
other types of inputs
that we want to use, we can just
refer to this examples page.
Here I'm in another
browser tab, and I can just
look for different
types of inputs to use.
[MUSIC PLAYING]